é eu resolvi sim pegar bem ao pé da
letra o que a palavra reflexão e eu fui
ver no dicionário que significava tem
duas e obviamente não vou ver tudo isso
mas tem duas que eu acho que são muito
interessantes
as duas primeiras porque elas falam
muito sobre você olhar pra você e você
entender e se refletir e entender que o
reflexo que você faz e que você causa
nas pessoas e foi olhando pra mim que dá
eu decidi voltar um pouco a nossa
conversa é eu vivi e eu cresci numa
época eu tenho 44 anos e eu é numa época
onde uma mulher chegar na posição que eu
cheguei ela pensava se masculinizar ela
precisa se vestir de terninho ela
precisava não ser vaidosa e ela
principalmente precisava abrir mão da
vida pessoal porque se ela optasse em
ser mãe ou se ela optasse em casar ou
ter um companheiro ela estaria fazendo
uma distração na carreira dela e eu
nunca acreditei nesse modelo e talvez
algumas mulheres talvez não com certeza
algumas mulheres sem saber me inspiraram
muito porque eram mulheres que naquela
época já estavam desafiando essa lógica
e aí eu olhei pra isso falei eu vou
desafiar isso eu não vou acreditar que é
possível e vou conseguir fazer as duas
coisas
é óbvio que cada escolha merece uma
renúncia e óbvio que em alguns momentos
da minha vida eu tive que fazer escolhas
que às vezes eu fui pra frente
às vezes eu fui pra trás e às vezes eu
fui pro lado mas durante a média na
minha trajetória mesmo eu sendo uma
mulher branca super privilegiada no país
que a gente tá se senna sido uma classe
média classe média brasileira
é óbvio que eu tive um monte de
privilégio mas eu também escutei muita
coisa ruim
eu escutei que mulher engravida e dá
trabalho
eu escutei piadas horrorosas
sobre a mulher e sobre o machismo e eu
escutei gente dizendo pra mim que eu não
ia chegar a lugar nenhum porque eu era
mulher
e aí eu tive acho que é um dos maiores
em sites da minha carreira e da minha
vida que é muita gente vai tentar
colocar vocês no lugar que não é o lugar
que vocês podem estar em um lugar que
eles acreditam que você deveria estar
mas não é o lugar que você deveria estar
então você deveria e para onde você
quiser e isso vai fazer com que você
tenha que tomar algumas decisões na sua
vida e na sua carreira
eu não sei se eu escolher essas marcas
ou seja as marcas me escolheram
mas ao longo da minha carreira eu
trabalhei com essas marcas e algumas nem
do trabalho
a primeira marca que eu trabalhei global
e muito forte ela me ensinou é algo
muito interessante que é você pode
vender mais que um produto como
profissional de marketing você pode
trabalhar com propósito e você pode
deixar um legado trabalhando com marcas
porque vocês sabem qual o percentual de
mulheres que se acham bonitas no mundo 2
por cento
essa é uma pesquisa que foi feita em
mais de dez países com 12 mil mulheres
ela é bem representativa
somente 2% das mulheres não mudaria nada
98% mudaria nariz cor do cabelo uma
série de coisas e quando eu percebi isso
eu vi que eu poderia estar fazendo parte
de um movimento muito interessante
há 13 anos atrás em 2005 essa marca
desafio o status da indústria de beleza
e ela colocou uma reflexão muito
importante para as mulheres porque as
mulheres estavam buscando um padrão de
beleza que não existia quererá falso
porque ele vinha cheio de photoshop
ele vinha cheio de uma série de retoques
que não existiam e isso estava
intrinsecamente ligado a autoestima das
mulheres
bom eu não sei se é porque aproveita
layout um dia mas hoje o meu cabelo é é
grisalho
mas vamos dizer que a
13 anos atrás eu tive esse tipo de
estímulo e eu comecei a perceber que
isso é o que fazia as mulheres se
libertarem dizendo que todas as mulheres
têm que aceitar e tem o cabelo grisalho
mas isso pra mim é uma liberdade e tem
muita gente que pergunta pra mim porque
eu faço isso como se eu tivesse me
penalizando como se fosse uma coisa ruim
eu aceitar que meu cabelo pode ser
grisalho
eu não eu acho bem górdios no meu caso é
curto e gór diz
mas enfim quando eu estava super bem
nessa posição estava trabalhando américa
latina brasil é eu decidi mudar e eu
decidi para o mercado super masculino e
super machista e recebi eu resolvi
trabalhar na indústria de cerveja
então eu saí do universo onde falava
sobre autoestima da mulher e eu fui para
um universo superior masculino
rio quando me deparei isso foi em 2010
quando me deparei com esse universo eu
percebi que era bem mais difícil do que
imaginava
porque infelizmente no brasil as marcas
de cerveja acreditavam que para vender
cerveja era pessoal era preciso
objetifica uma mulher era preciso
colocar uma mulher de biquíni na praia
para vender mais cerveja e eu nunca
acreditei também nesse modelo
então enquanto todo mundo ia para a
direita e para a esquerda enquanto todo
mundo colocava uma mulher de biquíni
eu não colocar uma mulher de biquíni
enquanto todo mundo objetivo objetifica
vá eu tentava falar de outros temas
e é nessa trajetória foram seis anos
trabalhando nessa categoria eu aprendi
que as pessoas estão muito mais
preparadas pra outro time ou outro tipo
de estímulo e quando você decide ir para
a esquerda
você tem muito mais chance de ter
sucesso porque está todo mundo indo para
a direita
você vai ser mais um e quando você não é
o líder do segmento vai ser mais difícil
ainda mas se você for pra esquerda vai
ser o único indo pra esquerda
então essa foi uma outra coisa que eu
percebi durante a minha carreira
o que você tem que ter coragem porque
ninguém nunca provou que para a esquerda
está certo pra direita todo mundo tá
provando que está dando certo mas a
audiência como eu falei é muito mais
preparada e foi uma das trajetórias mais
legais da minha carreira eu aprendi
muito e por que eu iria objetifica
mulheres e as mulheres eram 30% das
minhas consumidoras já parou pra pensar
que pode estar objetivo ficando a sua
consumidora
isso é bem sério por uma marca muito bem
depois é eu tive a oportunidade de fazer
o ovo vídeo mais visualizado da heineken
no mundo
esse vídeo foi feito pelo brasil no
brasil e ele quem já viu esse vídeo
legal dá um puto orgulho falar isso é
mas se a gente leva essa peça só como
uma peça publicitária ela tem um papel a
gente tá pra essa peça com uma peça que
usou o futebol pra falar de eqüidade de
gênero e para desafiar um status có
ela tem outro papel feito por uma marca
de cerveja no mercado super masculino
então o que eu aprendi aqui também é
como eu como profissional de marketing
posso usar as marcas e as categorias que
o trabalho para desafiar o status quo da
sociedade
e pra de verdade gerar ou causar uma
reflexão das pessoas sobre aquilo que eu
acredito que é relevante para o mundo é
pra quem não viu vale a pena ver mas é
ele foi feito aqui no brasil ele foi
parar em 20 países do mundo sem a gente
fazer nenhum esforço porquê porque tinha
uma tensão tão forte na provocação e na
reflexão que ele viajou
ele viajou e realmente foi algo eu acho
que foi o único viral da minha carreira
que eu fiz de verdade mas é um orgulho
enorme em saber
e de novo é quando você fala algo que é
relevante e que faz sentido é isso tem
um impacto nas pessoas muito grande
bom o que faria uma pessoa que estava na
posição que eu tava é sendo super
reconhecida resolver mudar porque
resolvi mandar eu resolvi que eu deveria
fazer um outro passo na minha carreira e
muita gente olhou pra mim e fez essa
cara assim não estou conseguindo
entender este movimento porque eu fiz
isso porque eu acreditei que eu poderia
causar mais reflexão das pessoas e eu
poderia causar mais provocação porque se
tem uma coisa que me move é fazer algo
que ou ninguém fez o que me dá um pouco
de dor de barriga quando me dá um pouco
de dor de barriga eu falo é tá certo
ciúme de dor de barriga eu acho que é um
pouco um dejá vu é mais do mesmo e aí é
eu comecei a olhar pra mim e comecei a
pensar que talvez eu pudesse ter um
outro papel também que não era o papel
só de usar marcas para provocar
reflexões e para deixar legados mas era
como uma profissional o líder de uma
empresa eu poderia atuar em políticas e
benefícios em prol de mulheres como eu
poderia tomar decisões se o que eu
acredito é isso como eu poderia tomar
decisões e eu fui é trabalhar na pepsico
ea pepsico é a empresa que eu trabalhei
que mais olha para a mulher que mais
entende que quanto mais oportunidade
você dá na base para as mulheres
mas essas mulheres vão ter um papel de
protagonismo liderança na sociedade e eu
tive uma grande oportunidade de conhecer
assim o global e ela me ensinou muita
coisa e ela me ensinou que não é só
sobre você está no seu papel de
marketing mas no seu papel de líder
dentro de uma grande empresa
e esse ano a gente lançou um programa
que chama mulheres com propósito que é
um programa que vai capacitar 12 mil
mulheres em condições de risco na
américa latina
e aqui é a foto da primeira certificação
de 88 mulheres já digo apenas que a
gente certificou é no mês passado e
essas mulheres receberam qualificação
pra voltar pro o universo de trabalho e
para poderem sustentar esse programa
nasceu com a meta de 50% mulheres
brancas e 50% mulheres negras a gente
conseguiu 75 por cento de mulheres
negras o que mostra que quando você dá
oportunidade
tem muita gente boa e tem muita gente
porque eu sempre escutei isso também é
que não tem mulher que não tem mulher
boa não tem a gente tem poucas mulheres
que não têm qualificação no mercado
é mentira tem muita gente boa no mercado
porque as pessoas não têm oportunidade
então eu olhei pra mim e falei como eu
posso dar a oportunidade para mais
mulheres e depois ao longo da minha
trajetória dentro da pepsico eu tive uma
outra oportunidade e de um grande
presente na minha vida que é trabalhar
com a questão da diversidade
a gente decidiu é fazer um lançamento no
brasil é bastante diferente porque toda
a verba desse produto é destinada a
capacitar transexuais que foram mais
marginalizados quando eles se assumiram
a família os amigos eu queria fazer uma
pergunta que fazer uma provocação eu
queria que na verdade se levantassem as
pessoas o que tem um amigo ou que tem
alguém na família o que é da comunidade
lgbt
no momento que você faz isso você mostra
que não é mais sobre eles é sobre nós ea
gente tem um papel enorme em fazer com
que a nossa sociedade seja muito melhor
pode sentar a gente que a nossa nossa
sociedade seja muito melhor muito mais
inclusive muito mais diversa então esse
foi um outro grande é eu falo que é um
presente porque não é fácil você
convencer uma empresa que você não vai
lucrar nada com o lançamento de um
produto que você vai reverter tudo isso
em prol da sociedade
mas eu tenho uma empresa que acredita
nisso e eu acho que isso também é um
dado muito importante que é o trabalho
no lugar que acredita no que eu acredito
que tem os mesmos valores e que me dá
espaço para atuar para fazer isso
isso também é uma das pessoas que foi
aprendendo ao longo da minha carreira
que é esteja no lugar que você possa de
verdade aplicar o que você acredita que
você possa de verdade ter o reflexo do
que você acredita
e não é só estar na mente é internamente
porque a gente tem um programa super
robusto de inclusão e muita gente fala é
a diversidade e inclusão
a inclusão é o que garante a
sustentabilidade da diversidade
não adianta falar sobre diversidade só
tem que se falar sobre políticas de
benefícios que garantam a inclusão e é
sobre isso que a gente está trabalhando
agora para terminar eu termino com os
dois primeiros pontos que falam que a
gente é o reflexo em internamento
externamente do que a gente acredita
então eu encorajo vocês a primeiro
acreditarem que podem chegar onde quiser
chegar saber que vai ter uma série de
barreiras mas eu não sei se eu tenho um
processo quase que de audição seletiva
onde tem algumas coisas que entram por
aqui outras ali por aqui isso não vai me
deter e que vocês saibam que vão ter
muita gente vai tentar não deixar você
chegar vocês chegarem mas se vocês
acreditarem na sua verdade na sua
autenticidade
de entenderem que o reflexo do que vocês
são
vocês podem levar para a sociedade com
certeza vão ter sucesso
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]